Foundation Researcher Marcus Hernandez was
a professional in all aspects of his job.
He was intelligent, being scouted for a job
at the Foundation right out of college.
He was brave, unyielding in the faces of the
horrifying creatures and dangerous situations
that working with the anomalous practically
guaranteed.
But most importantly, Researcher Hernandez
was cautious.
He not only knew that keeping his hands at
a fair distance from any newly discovered
anomalous objects was a safe way to keep his
head, he was also aware that it was sometimes
better to take risks that would further his
knowledge about an anomaly and how best to
contain it.
Sometimes those risks came with a price, like
being a part of the first team to study a
recently discovered anomaly.
To Researcher Hernandez, it was better to
lose the lives of the ones working to protect
humanity from what lies in the dark than have
any unsuspecting civilians stumble upon something
potentially life threatening.
That’s why he and his team took the assignment
of studying SCP-1437 before anyone else in
the Foundation was able to.
They simply were not sure of what it was capable
of, and their Researcher Hernandez’s known
attention to detail and cautious nature could
best help the Foundation not only establish
proper containment procedures, but also ensure
that their own personnel were safe while doing
so.
As Researcher Hernandez sat in the back of
a jeep that rolled and tumbled over the arid
landscape of the Mojave Desert, he reviewed
what the Foundation knew about the anomaly.
Unfortunately, it wasn’t much.
For starters, it was a 3 by 3 meter hole in
the ground, originally thought to be an ordinary
cave.
As a result of its deceiving appearance, the
anomaly went unnoticed for decades until the
Foundation picked up on a local story that
was the talk of the town for a small group
of camping and hiking hobbyists in Nevada.
A camper, while out exploring and trekking
through the dry dunes of the Mojave, was struck
in the back of the neck with a US quarter.
While the object by itself is harmless, it
came flying at the camper’s body at an incredibly
high speed, shooting from a large hole in
the ground and striking hard enough to break
the skin and wedge itself inside the camper’s
neck.
After reaching the local hospital and getting
the coin removed, it still left a small scar
across the back of the camper’s head.
This unusual event prompted Foundation reconnaissance,
which turned out to be entirely warranted,
as observation of the surrounding area found
several more objects buried around the area
that were believed to have emerged from the
hole now designated as SCP-1437.
A small canoe, decorated with luminescent
patterns, a calculator that added and subjected
letters instead of numbers, and a rotten apple
core were all objects strewn across the immediate
area, and if that’s not strange enough,
attempts to map out the hole failed, as all
measuring equipment was lost after reaching
a certain depth.
Before the initial observation team packed
up and left, SCP-1437 shot out large quantities
of rock and dirt for over an hour, confirming
that objects emerged from the hole at high
speeds.
Chemical analysis of the objects found around
the area showed that they were composed of
materials either unknown or not commonly found
on Earth to warrant use in mass production.
The observation team came up with a hypothesis
- SCP-1437 was a hole that led to a parallel
universe, and the objects it shot out originated
in said location.
Researcher Hernandez knew that this was just
a hypothesis, but he had reviewed the lab
results himself.
Those objects certainly did not come from
anywhere on Earth, and if the hole functioned
as a gateway between worlds, that could explain
why the measuring equipment was lost after
a certain point.
The jeep came to a stop, and when Researcher
Hernandez stepped out, he came face to face
with SCP-1437, a large hole sitting in the
Mojave desert.
His crew was already hard at work, surveying
and excavating the surrounding area for any
other objects the hole had shot out that had
been lost to time.
A mobile analysis lab tent was set up in the
distance, as well as several trailers for
personnel living on-site.
Researcher Hernandez’s personal decision
to not use D-Class personnel in his research
meant that each risk the SCP-1437 team took
had to be calculated differently.
They wouldn’t send a person into the hole
and risk loss of life when a drone could serve
the same function without the potential drawbacks.
But still, the initial observation team lost
all of their equipment while trying to measure
SCP-1437’s depth.
Why waste an expensive drone when the result
would most likely turn out the same?
It was these decisions that earned Hernandez
fame and respect at the Foundation, and over
the next few weeks, his team was able to develop
a wide knowledge base regarding SCP-1437 and
establish safe containment procedures to keep
the anomaly hidden from the public and easy
to work with for Foundation personnel.
First, a two meter tall electric fencing unit
was built around the perimeter of SCP-1437.
This fence would not only keep unwanted trespassers
out, but also had defensive capabilities due
to the harmful electric charge it could emit
upon contact with an object.
Groups of three security guard personnel were
assigned to patrol this fence at all times,
and they were instructed to deal with any
trespassers through standard Foundation protocol.
They were to be taken into custody, interrogated,
and so long as they were unaware of SCP-1437’s
anomalous properties, given a healthy dose
of amnestics and released back into the general
public.
Anything that emerged from SCP-1437, be it
a physical object or a living organism would
be catalogued by the Foundation and tested
immediately for any potential hazards before
further analysis could begin.
If found to be safe, the items would be studied
as much as possible.
If not, they were stowed away in an area intended
to keep them contained until a safe way to
examine them was found.
But perhaps the most important containment
procedure Researcher Hernandez established
was the forbiddance of testing with SCP-1437.
Due to the anomaly’s mysterious nature and
the incredibly likely potential connection
to parallel universes, testing could have
grave and unforeseen consequences.
When dealing with alternate or parallel timelines
or realities, the Foundation is incredibly
cautious, and only interacts in ways they’re
absolutely sure will not have any unexpected
damage on baseline reality.
That, and Researcher Hernandez wasn’t exactly
keen on attracting the attention of these
parallel universes without a solid understanding
of who and what they were.
As he would come to find, this inclination
proved to be beneficial.
As the team observed SCP-1437, they documented
a number of notable objects that emerged from
the hole, each supposedly originating from
a parallel world.
The first of which, however, was not anything
the team hadn’t seen before.
The initial observation team sent to test
whether SCP-1437 was actually anomalous had
observed the hole emitting a mass of rock
and dirt.
For over an hour, SCP-1437 spewed earthen
materials without stopping, filling the surrounding
areas with debris.
Since this was before the research team theorized
the hole was connected to parallel realities,
they weren’t sure what to make of it.
Was it a natural eruption?
A poorly documented earthquake that somehow
sent chunks of rock and dirt to the surface
and shooting out of the hole?
Though somewhat stumped, Researcher Hernandez’s
team eventually came to a single, solid conclusion:
If SCP-1437 led to a parallel world or worlds,
whoever was on the other ‘side’ of the
hole may have been attempting to fill it using
natural materials.
If they were attempting to fill it, could
they be trying to contain it?
Did the parallel world on the other side of
SCP-1437 have its own Foundation?
This sudden thought gave Researcher Hernandez
pause, and made him reconsider his hands-off
approach to SCP-1437.
Should his team attempt to contact whoever
was on the other side?
If it was a parallel branch of the Foundation,
this behavior would be encouraged.
The Foundation communicated with alternate
versions of itself in time and space all of
the time.
The Department of Temporal Anomalies was built
around this premise.
But these were exceptions, not the rules,
and communication with alternate Foundations
was always carried out with utmost safety
and precaution.
It was only done when there was certainty
that risk would be avoided.
Researcher Hernandez was sure he made the
correct decision, and he would stray away
from attempting to contact those on the other
side of the anomaly, even if they were another
world’s incarnation of the SCP Foundation.
Weeks later, Researcher Hernandez was awoken
in the middle of the night by an excited assistant,
who, after calming herself down, informed
him that SCP-1437 had spat out a new object.
You have to forgive her, if you were out in
the desert for weeks staring at a hole waiting
for it to do something and it eventually did
it, you’d be pretty excited too.
When Researcher Hernandez ran outside to see
what the team was freaking out about, he could
have jumped for joy too.
SCP-1437 wasn’t spitting out rocks and dirt
anymore.
This time, it was a map, clearly illustrated
to depict the continent of North America.
But upon closer inspection, the team noticed
some very apparent differences from a traditional
map and the geography of our world.
The map was written entirely in Spanish, and
the names of countries and states it listed
didn’t match their existing counterparts.
In fact, the entire borderlines of the map
were mismatched, out of place, and radically
different from anything resembling North America.
It listed the government of the entire continent
of North America as “La República Popular
de Aguas Nuevas”, or when translated to
english, “The People’s Republic Of New
Waters”.
This exciting find was logged and archived,
and was only the first of a series of objects
that emerged from SCP-1437.
A few days later, another object was documented.
This time, it was a photograph.
After initial scans determined the object
to be safe to view, not harboring any dangerous
memetic triggers upon viewing or anything
of that nature, the team analyzed the picture
to the best of their abilities.
They saw a breathtaking vista of a city skyline,
unlike anything possible on this world.
Intertwined with buildings were massive structures
that appeared to be made of coral.
They wrapped around skyscrapers, branching
from the ground and sometimes emerging from
the buildings themselves.
The coral broke through the tops of the tallest
buildings, putting the manmade titans to shame.
In the far background, a massive flying creature
can be seen, peacefully floating through the
air.
This otherworldly visual overwhelmed the team,
but after the initial shock wore down, a keen-eyed
junior researcher pointed out that many of
the buildings resembled known landmarks, though
they were radically altered in noticeable
ways.
This wasn’t just any city, it was New York
City, only this time with coral and giant,
floating creatures!
Exactly what the Big Apple’s been missing
this entire time.
But this was still comprehensible and understandable
for the Foundation.
SCP-1437’s true weirdness was still yet
to come.
A few days after the photograph emerged, SCP-1437
shot out a truly peculiar find.
Researcher Hernandez and his team were stumped
as to what its purpose was, and what it signified,
but they determined the objects to be completely
safe, and archived them regardless.
The items in question were a series of disks
made from solid gold, varying in size but
never being obscenely large.
Accompanying the discs was a sheet of paper
that read “PLEASE SEND MORE RAIN”.
The Foundation was understandably puzzled.
One working theory Researcher Hernandez put
together was that whoever was on the opposite
side of SCP-1437 was paying tribute to the
hole as a form of worship, and was asking
the almighty beings on the other side to send
more rain, for whatever reason.
While the Foundation didn’t exactly send
the rain over themselves, whoever sent that
request was probably pleased when a thunderstorm
the next week sent torrents of rainwater into
SCP-1437.
We hope they’re happy.
The most notable discoveries that emerged
from SCP-1437 occurred over a multi-year period.
Previously, the research team theorized that
SCP-1437 was connected to a single reality,
and that whoever was on the other side of
it was sending objects through, either by
chance or by means of communication.
This discovery proved that there wasn’t
just one parallel world connected to SCP-1437,
but many.
An unknown amount, in fact.
The items in question this time weren’t
just objects, but human cadavers.
One by one over the years, interspaced between
the various oddities that SCP-1437 also spat
out, were human corpses, dead on arrival.
The bodies were clad in Foundation-issue D-Class
uniforms, though with some slight variations.
This proved that the worlds connected to SCP-1437
were, in fact, alternate versions of the Foundation.
Or at least some of the worlds, as there was
no way to tell who, what, or where the objects
that emerged from SCP-1437 came from.
Researcher Hernandez and his team examined
the bodies with care, and determined that
they were dead long before they hit the ground,
and that the gateway between worlds triggered
the cause of death as they traveled between
realities.
Inside the D-Class jumpsuits, the team discovered
pieces of paper.
Manuscripts that detailed their world’s
Foundation’s documentation on SCP-1437.
This deliberate inclusion of documentation
signaled to the research team that there was
an attempt at communication and cooperation
from one world’s Foundation to theirs.
But why?
The first body was clearly in adequate physical
condition.
It was protected due to being clothed in a
pressure suit with an attached oxygen supply.
The documentation read similarly to the SCP
Foundation’s documentation, though instead
of Special Containment Procedures and an object
class, SCP-1437 was given a “Safety Rating”
and “Safety Containment Procedures”.
These detailed a Foundation that was giving
civilians tours of their anomalies, where
they could take photographs and even get close
enough to view the anomaly from a close distance.
The rest of the file was similar to what Hernandez’s
team recorded, and listed the following objects
as those that emerged from SCP-1437:
One small pyramid composed of concrete.
Large quantities of dirt and rocks.
A landscape painting, believed to be of a
location in Scotland.
(According to the painting, its originating
universe's sun is blue and its sky yellow.)
Several disks made from solid gold.
(Accompanying the disks was a sheet of paper
reading 'PLEASE STOP PLAGUE'.)
A photograph of several scientists.
(All scientists pictured have unusually long
fingers, estimated to be nearly twenty-five
(25) centimeters long.)
A sheet of paper reading "THANK YOU PLEASE
SEND MORE GIFTS."
The file continued with a notice explaining
that the bodies of “orange jumpsuited individuals”
holding documentation of the anomaly emerged
from the hole.
The file’s unfamiliarity with the jumpsuits
indicate that this world lacks a concept of
D-Class personnel.
The file mentions that “On the 15th of August
2012, a volunteer from the Foundation, Marco
Perton, entered SCP-1437 wearing safety gear,
taking with him a copy of this document.”
The second D-class body examined by Hernandez’s
team was branded with the phrase “PROPERTY
OF THE SCP CORPORATION”.
The file described an item with a threat level
of “little”, and a Foundation that was
more focused on profit than containment.
After objects emerged from the hole, they
were authorized to be sold to any interested
collectors.
Objects described by this version of the Foundation
include:
A statue of what is believed to be a reptilian
entity sporting numerous eyes and tails.
Large quantities of dirt and rocks.
A glass bottle of water.
A human femur.
(Covered in saliva.)
A cube composed of several smaller cubes,
all of which are different colours.
(Purpose unknown.)
A soccer ball.
(Ball only has five sides.)
The file included the SCP corporation describing
D-Class showing up, as they did in the other
worlds, and then the Corporation happily sending
several D-Class of their own through the hole
in an attempt to communicate with whoever
was on the other side.
The third D-Class body examined was heavily
bandaged and appeared to be blinded.
There were lacerations on its arms and legs,
and its tongue had been removed.
The file described a Foundation akin to a
religious cult.
SCP-1437 was given a “Heathen Level” of
“Unforgivable”, and its “Holding Measures”
described a High Priest having to bless the
hole every two years, and the need to perform
blood sacrifices into it to ward off any demons.
This wild incarnation of the Foundation interpreted
SCP-1437 as a portal to the underworld, and
described a list of objects emerging from
it.
It read as follows:
Several disks made from solid gold.
(Accompanying the disk was a sheet of paper
reading 'PLEASE KILL FOES'.)
Large quantities of dirt and rocks.
(Believed to be an attempt by demons to harm
the High Priest, who was present at the holding
site at the time.)
The broken remains of a human arm.
(Covered in saliva.)
A photograph of a metal bird flying away from
a city.
What appears to be a large mushroom is visible
behind the bird.
(Believed to be attempt by demons at mocking
us.)
A human eye which moved when touched.
(Believed to be a lesser demon.
Was burnt immediately.)
Unlike the other worlds, when this one received
D-class through SCP-1437, the religious fanatics
believed the bodies to be demons wearing the
skin of men, and threw the bodies back in
the hole.
The next D-Class body observed by Hernandez’s
team was the most curious.
It was a heavily emaciated child, who had
apparently been lobotomized.
It described a Foundation that sounds more
like an organization out of a dystopian science
fiction novel than anything else.
The file spoke of a group of beings referred
to as “Our Masters Above All”, which the
Foundation answered to.
Any objects emerging from SCP-1437 were brought
before the Masters.
Any trespassers were interrogated by the Masters.
This Foundation believed the objects SCP-1437
shot out were gifts for the masters.
Their list read as follows:
One (1) diamond.
Large quantities of dirt and rocks.
Bark from the extinct Quercus buckleyi.
The lower half of a human body.
(Delivered to supervising Servant of Our Masters
Above.
It is currently unknown how the gift-sender
was aware of the diet of Our Masters Above.
A document was sent into SCP-1437 thanking
the gift-giver for the object and requesting
further tributes to Our Masters Above.)
A bottle of human-intended wine.
While they certainly enjoyed the food of the
human body, the wine was clearly misinterpreted.
For whatever reason, this Foundation interpreted
the wine as an assassination attempt on the
Masters Above All.
As a result, they sent a large, anomalously
powered explosive through SCP-1437 and into
the world of an unsuspecting Foundation.
The file continues with a notice from this
Foundation’s O5-1, which reads: “This
is a reminder of why we must be vigilant in
our containment procedures.
From now on, I don't want any of these 'gifts'
being taken out of containment.
They are a clear and present danger to Our
Masters Above.”
Looks like Researcher Hernandez had the correct
idea about not wanting to risk experimenting
with SCP-1437.
Attracting the attention of a reality where
the almighty O5 Council answers to an even
more powerful, human-eating group of Masters
Above All?
No thank you!
This reality’s Foundation is perfectly content
alone.
Now go check out SCP-1322 - Glory Hole and
SCP-3001 - Red Reality for more anomalous
Parallel Universe-related SCPs!